Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my full The Last of Us Episode 1 video. There's
a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel I will be doing videos for all the
episodes just like I do for House of the Dragon
just like I do for the Marvel Disney plus Series
be sure to subscribe to get everything it is just
getting started it's only going to get crazier if
you have not played the games they are amazing I
would highly recommend it season one is following
the events of the first game future seasons will
follow the events of the second game and then
I think that they're planning on making the
last of us three eventually and they'll probably
adapt that as well careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet we'll start
at the beginning and just work our way through
shot by shot talking about Easter eggs and WTF
moments starting with the episode title it was
called when you're lost in the darkness and
it's a reference to the fireflies motto there
are catchphrase that's written on some of their
symbols the graffiti that's all over the place
the full phrase goes when you're lost in the
darkness look for the light the reason they're
using this for the title of episode one is because
it's all about Joel meeting Ellie for the first
time and learning about the fireflies Mission the
fireflies are rogue group within the United States
in the game who try to oppose the military regime
that's currently controlling the majority of the
United States through all these quarantined
zones and as they say in the episode it's a
form of dictatorship like life is generally really
bad for everyone inside the zones they want to get
rid of them and install a civilian government more
akin to what things used to be like in the United
States thinking that they'll better be able to
tackle the fungus and create a vaccine from Ellie
Joel's whole mission throughout season one will be
to get Ellie to the other fireflies on the other
side of the United States so that they can study
her and create a vaccine easier said than done
the reason why they ended the episode with the
80s song is because the 80s songs were code for
trouble is coming and that was meant to be a big
metaphor foreshadowing for not only episode two
but also the rest of the entire series like if you
think things are bad now just you wait a couple
more episodes but the actual opening scene is a
flashback to 1968 to set up the whole cordyceps
virus and explain how it works and how the initial
outbreak worked it's one of the big differences
between a series like this which is similar to
The Walking Dead and it is post-apocalyptic and
you're talking about this giant outbreak but
the main difference is that you actually find
out at the very beginning here like literally
in the opening scene what actually caused the
outbreak whereas they never really addressed that
during The Walking Dead the official name of the
fungus is the cordyceps brain infection or CBI
because of the way it takes over people's brains
in the scientists there talk about it like oh it
takes over your brain it needs to consume more
to grow and it slowly mutates the body which is a
reference to all the different stages of infection
in the different types of infected that they'll
encounter like during The Walking Dead you have
the zombie Walkers like they're called walkers but
during the last of us there are several different
kinds of these creatures with each different
names and different abilities like they slowly
mutate and gain extra abilities and become harder
and harder to kill there are two main ways to get
infected like a bite or by inhaling spores that
are given off by the bodies of the infected after
destroyed so even after you kill one of them it's
not over they give off spores and can continue to
infect a other people which is why they're so much
more dangerous than your average Walker from The
Walking Dead and they also imply in this opening
scene that global warming was the real reason
for the initial outbreak because under a certain
degree the fungus couldn't spread the same way and
it is based on a real world type of fungus like it
actually exists so the whole idea is that global
warming raised the temperature levels of the
planet just enough so that the fungus could spread
so it's kind of meant to be a cautionary Tale in
present day the intro scene depicts the growth
and spread of the fungus itself across a map of
the United States like you see the fungus growing
but you can see the outline of the United States
the rest of the planet as it spreads across it
really quickly and that is part of the idea like
the fungus itself spreads extremely quickly once
you get infected the opening theme song is also
the original Last of Us theme song from the game
they're about five different stages five different
main types of infected after just a little while
they turn into what are called Runners they start
biting people like Regular walkers from Walking
Dead just super fast then after a little while
longer they evolve into stalkers getting a little
bit more dangerous a little bit more tough to kill
stage three after about a month of being infected
they turn into clickers and look like this they
gain the ability of echolocation because they
essentially lose their sight then even later they
can evolve into bloaters where the fungus turns
their hives like their skin into Ultra hard armor
so they're super super hard to kill and they gain
the ability to throw Spore bombs which can also
infect people if they progress to stage five they
turn into shamblers and gain the ability to throw
acid just even harder to kill so you get the idea
we're going to encounter several different
types throughout the series we saw Runners
during episode one we might see all the way up to
clickers during episode two but then they actually
change the timeline just a little bit there's a
small change from the game so when they pick up
in 2003 that's actually 10 years before the video
games the video games picked up in 2013 when Sarah
and Joel were living together but it's just meant
to show you Joel's life before the outbreak with
his daughter they're living in Austin Texas he's a
construction worker with his brother raising Sarah
alone he's meant to generally be a good person
it forshadows a lot of his actions later on in
the story like he jokes about his brother Tommy
needing him to survive and later in the story part
of the reason why he's trying to get the battery
is so he can get supplies to his brother thinking
that it will help him survive in Wyoming we meet
Tommy who's played by Gabriel Luna he's going to
be a big character later in the story most of you
probably remember him is Ghost Rider in the Marvel
series he's also generally meant to be a good
person Sarah pulls out the watch that she winds
up giving Joel on his birthday which is his only
reminder of her in present day he constantly kept
it on him and it still does not work in present
day a lot of these scenes in the flashback here
are expanded from the video game like the video
game does have a flashback to explain how this all
happened but it's much bigger in the episode just
to give you a better sense for what he was like
before things went crazy the military bumper
sticker on his truck is just to let you know
that they used to be soldiers they had a certain
level of training that helps them survive in the
apocalypse like he is a man with a certain set of
skills and I love the way that you're just kind of
waiting for things to go nuts like you just start
to see weird things happening in the background
more and more Sirens more military planes
flying over the whole idea with the spread
of the fungus is that it is super quick if you
get infected typically you start turning within a
couple hours you get super creeped out the minute
they introduce that old lady to like you're just
waiting for that old lady to get up out of that
chair and turn into a runner part of the reason
why she turns first and not like the dog or the
other people is because she's immunocompromised
so her body has an even harder time fighting off
the fungus but part of the idea is that pretty
much everybody is susceptible to the fungus if
you come into contact with it you will wind up
getting infected but there are just like a couple
exceptions Ellie being the first one that they
find out about way way way later in the story they
do introduce more characters who also have similar
immunity to La so like she's not the only person
in the entire planet that's immune to it it's just
that she's the only person that they know about
in the United States right now that's immune to
it when she winds up giving Joel the watch and
starts talking about being an honest Thief that's
more foreshadowing for him later on like he's a
Smuggler by trade at least at the beginning he
doesn't really care about Ellie but slowly winds
up being getting to care for her like he cared for
his daughter she's basically like a surrogate
daughter to him they have a funny reference to
the video games the Curtis the Viper movie is a
franchise that's featured in the games a couple of
different places Ellie comes across one of their
posters in the second game too when you start to
hear explosions you see the military started to
create blockades all around the city we're talking
about Austin Texas here but the idea is that this
is happening all over the United States it's part
of the reason why Boston looks so bad in present
day because the military blows it up thinking that
that will contain the fungus unsuccessfully of
course the Hawaii is the military rolls in and
basically just starts shooting everyone on site
that's why they're not letting anybody out of
the city because when things start to go crazy
the whole idea is that just within the United
States in general the military are the only
people who are briefed on the true extent of
the fungus nobody else has any idea what's going
on why things are going crazy when they make their
break for it they try to actually escape the city
they want to show you some of Tommy and Joel's
skills thinking on the fly like the plans always
go to crap they always have to come up with a new
plan on the Fly that that will just continue
to be a thing throughout all the episodes the
entire series to show you how he wound up losing
his daughter the military winds up stopping them
from escaping and gets an order from his Superior
to basically kill anybody no matter what that's
what he's talking to is superior about like you
want me to do it okay fine you're not infected
doesn't matter we're shooting everybody on site
his brother Tommy does wind up saving him but
Sarah isn't so lucky and she dies in his arms it
winds up breaking him and it's just meant to show
you why he is the way he is in present day he
doesn't turn into a total Dirtbag but just in
general he doesn't really care about the rest of
humanity he only cares at least before he meets
La before he gets close to her he only cares
about his brother this is going to continue to
be a big idea with his character through the rest
of the series The whole idea of the needs of the
many versus the needs of the few the whole idea
that he cares more about Ellie than he does about
everybody then they jump forward 20 years and it
explains why they moved the timeline back a little
bit because in the present day of the series is
2023 our real world present day like they want
to make the series feel like it could potentially
happen like this could potentially be our reality
you see that nature has slowly begun to retake the
planet the reason Boston is in Ruins like I said
is because the military basically tried to bomb
it to contain the fungus unsuccessfully and in
the aftermath they erected one of the quarantine
zones around what had survived of the city there's
versions of these quarantine zones in a lot of
the big cities around the United States this isn't
meant to be the only one there are a couple other
big ones the little kid arriving is meant to be a
tutorial for how Society just works in general how
the military rule over Society works at this point
new visitors coming to the quarantine Zone get
rigorously tested for the fungus they strap him
down in the chair so that he can't escape if he
has been infected they show you these devices that
they use to test people for the infected that'll
be a big thing and it's also meant to foreshadow
the end of the episode when they reveal Ellie's
immunity the red light on this is also meant to
show you that this kid is also positive for the
fungus so when she gives him that soft speech
about oh everything's going to be fine here's some
medicine make you feel better it's actually her
lying and they're essentially euthanizing him we
meet the older Joel he's still wearing the watch
that his daughter gave him it still doesn't work
which Ellie references later in the episode oh by
the way your watch doesn't work he wears it as a
reminder of his daughter it's more of a memorial
to her than an actual timepiece used for keeping
time they show you what his daily life is like
inside the quarantine Zone just doing regular jobs
when he's not smuggling things like that is his
major trait is being a Smuggler they reference the
rations that's also what he's trading the soldier
for later the white is that the military uses
those to ration out food to people but there's
never enough to go around which is why he is
needed as a Smuggler because he smuggles in
food amongst a lot of other things they show you
what life is like under military rule they execute
anyone found to be violating any of their rules
like breaking into the Zone trying to leave the
Zone that'll get you killed the show is smuggling
in action with him trading rations for drugs the
fedra that the soldier mentions is the federal
Disaster Response agency they're basically the
organization that control this military like this
Soldier is a soldier of fedra they're kind of like
the alternate universe version of FEMA the vehicle
that he's trying to trade for in the battery that
he's trying to get is so that he can get tests and
get to his brother in Wyoming thinking that he's
going to save his brother from dying like he needs
the supplies that I'm going to be bringing him the
soldier references the fireflies the explosions
in the dark which is another reference to their
motto the fireflies that he's talking about is
them blowing up the military and stuff they're
very militaristic organization themselves like
them trying to overthrow the military isn't
a pacifistic operation as we see when we meet
Tess Joel's current girlfriend and partner in a
smuggling operation the reason she's interrogating
this person is because they've been scanned out of
the battery that Joel needs to get the truck to
Tommy this is also right out of the game a lot
of the scenes in episode 1 were right out of the
game the only minor change here is that in the
game they got scammed out of guns instead of being
scammed out of a battery when she's interrogating
him the explosion is the fireflies blowing up
one of the military's trucks right outside the
building and they find out later that they're
the ones who are going to buy the stolen battery
that they got scammed out of which is how Joel
winds up meeting Ellie and going on this Mission
turns out jokes on all them because the battery
was bad to begin with like nobody was going to
be able to use the battery We Meet Ellie for the
first time played by Bella Ramsey who's also from
Game of Thrones she played the little bear Pedro
Pascal also from Game of Thrones a lot of Game of
Thrones going on during the series but it's HBO
that's making it so it makes sense she's being
interrogated by the fireflies as you see their
motto Written in Blood up on the wall they want to
give you a sense for what her personality is like
you get a little bit of that in episode one she's
only about 14 years old when the series picks
up but she's very precocious and she is kind of
able to take care of herself but she slowly comes
into her own and eventually winds up saving Joel a
couple times later on the radio facility that Joel
winds up going to is relaying messages for people
inside the quarantine Zone to other parts of the
United States and he's been trying to contact his
brother Tommy for the past three weeks to find
out what's going on with him because he's been
living in Wyoming recently that's where Joel's
planning on going with tests and then later with
Ellie once he takes on Ellie's Mission they show
you a little of what his life is like with tests
what their home life is like they're generally
meant to be decent people but they're not total
dirt bags or anything like that but they're
just focused on survival and Joel only cares
about saving his brother at the moment like the
whole idea is that nobody is a saint like he's a
good thief as his daughter foreshadowed earlier in
the story we meet Marlene who's the leader of this
group of fireflies in Boston she's also a really
big character during the first game so she's going
to continue to be a big character throughout the
series she's generally a good person as well doing
her best to survive and further their cause of
overthrowing the military but they do want to
show you that there's no love lost between Joel
and the fireflies part of the reason for that
because the Firefly comes up and tries to recruit
him he's like get out of here or I will kill you
is because he blames the fireflies for turning
his brother against him his brother Tommy used
to be part of the fireflies but then he left the
group and moved to Wyoming which is where Joel's
trying to go to before things go south Marlene
is planning on using all the fireflies in Boston
to Stage a mass escape to get Ellie out of the
city like she's got all the fireflies in Boston
that are planning on this big operation but the
whole idea is that by the time the Joel and Tess
have found their group not knowing that it's going
to be the fireflies that they're going to get the
drop on when they show up Robert had tried to sell
them the battery that deal went South and led to
a gunfight killing most of the fireflies which is
why when Joel shows up they need his help to get
Ellie out like okay fine we don't have anybody
else that can do this Joel please do this for
us and we will give you a ton of free stuff so
Joel winds up meeting Ellie for the first time
and they kind of want to give you a Vibe for
their relationship at least at first like he
doesn't really care about her he puts the gun
on her like please don't kill her just to show
you how far his Arc comes like he goes from
not caring about her all to eventually caring
for her like she's his own daughter even to the
detriment of the rest of humanity Marlene also
explains a little bit about Ellie's importance
to the story like she lets her know oh I'm the
person that put you in military school to keep
you safe she knew her real name and she knows
about the fact that she's immune to the virus
that's what she's talking about when she says
her greater purpose eventually the fireflies
on the other side of the United States using
her to create a vaccine or at least they hope and
if it wasn't clear Ellie also knows this too like
she knows that she is immune and that they plan
on using her for a vaccine it's not like that's
a surprise to her or anything like that back at
their place La learns about Bill and Frank who
are huge characters from the games everybody's
been really excited to see I believe we'll run
into them during episode two like they're featured
in the episode 2 trailer but they might also be in
episode three they're the ones that helped Joel
get the car that he needs in order to actually
physically get Ellie across the United States to
the other fireflies so they're critical to his
plan she references the broken watch causing
him to have a flashback to his daughter when
he falls asleep and that's meant to foreshadow
him beginning to think of her as his surrogate
daughter the whole joke about her breaking Joel's
music code on the Fly just a minute to show you
that she's resourceful too like she comes into
her own throughout the story like I said she also
winds up saving Joel's life a number of times all
their scenes of The Escape when the storm starts
it's all right out of the video games the guard
that they encounter is the one that he just got
done trading the pills to the test is also meant
to show you that Ellie is infected and reveal the
secret that she is immune to the virus but it
sounds like they push a lot of the revelations
of that to episode 2 because they escape into the
outer quarantine zone of Boston the cry that here
in the background is one of the infected that
they'll wind up facing like as we start to see
more and more stages of being infected I don't
know if it's going to wind up being a clicker
they might show us some clickers in episode two
like I said it goes from Runners then you turn
into a stalker then you turn into a clicker then
you turn into a bloater so let's just encounter
more and more dangerous types of infected and the
reason why they end on the Depeche Mode song never
let me down again one is to alert them of danger
like the military is coming for them retaliating
after finding what they did to the guard also just
in general it's meant to foreshadow trouble coming
for them for the rest of the series like it's
really getting bad now in the lyrics and the
title are more literally a reference to Joel not
letting Ellie down keeping her alive unlike his
daughter and their trip across the United States
overall it was a great episode it sounds like
it's going to be an S tier video game adaptation
hopefully the God of War series winds up being
as good as this let me know if you spotted any
Easter eggs or references in the episode that
I didn't mention in the video they are following
the video game plot pretty closely but there will
be some additions like some characters that were
not in the video game they do have cameos coming
from video game actors Ellie's mother is being
played by Ashley Johnson who voiced Ellie in the
video game and Troy Baker who voiced Joel in the
game will be playing one of the villains that they
encounter during winter in later episodes My Last
of Us episode 2 trailer video will post tomorrow
and they're also releasing the Mandalorian
season 3 trailer tomorrow night so of course
we'll do a video for that too after it releases
talk about Pedro Pascal crossover Pedro Pascal
into the Pascal verse the funny thing about that
too is that the plot of The Last of Us isn't too
different from the Mandalorian with him trying
to protect very young helpless beings the funny
thing about that too is that he actually had to
get special permission from John Favreau and Dave
filoni the Mandalorian people in order to even do
the Last of Us series like please will you let me
also film this other series everyone click here
for my Last of Us episode 2 trailer video I'll
update the link as soon as I post that and click
here for my house the Dragon season 2 teaser video